you guys have a lot of you're on the
road a lot with different shows you have
a show now uh Nick called American ham
yeah that's going to be coming out on
Netflix uh this summer and um I'm
starting a new show we actually have we
got sick of being a part while we're
touring with our disperate acts and so
we've written a show together that we're
uh our first show is in two weeks in
Washington DC it's called Summer of 69
no
apostrophe no apostrophe
all
right and uh now we're we're playing the
D Constitution Hall it's going to be
quite explicit uh and we're going to do
as many positions as we can before they
shut us down that's great so this
doesn't seem like it's aiming to be a
long running show either this
time and I have a band called Nancy and
Beth and we tour around and do funny
things and this is where you can see you
playing ukulele yes uh yes and my band
partner plays ukulele also but you also
rap yes we do a lot of tender love songs
one or two of them may be rap songs do
you rap them as raps or do you sing a
rap song would you like to hear a
sampling one of the more
romantic this is
I I don't I mean I know we're trying to
do comedy but this is one of the more
sort of tender romantic ones I love how
she be swallowing my then she be
throwing me up love how she but then I
hate when she be blowing me up all the
buses just sweat her only Ballers can
get her she a flipper I love how she do
whatever I tell
her I
uh I feel like I I just want to
apologize to Jeff our beep guy who's got
to stay late tonight sorry
Jeff I think it was his kid's birthday
it's all right it's all and your Show on
Netflix so this is a a stage show that's
going to be on Netflix it is it's it's
my touring a show as a humorist uh it's
my 10 tips for a prosperous life with
songs and minor
nudity what are what are a couple if you
can give them away for free what are a
couple of your tips for Prosperity say
please and thank you um and uh avoid the
mirror avoid the mirror yeah as far as
just never looking in one or yeah if if
I never look in the mirror and I think
I'm a good-looking son of a
and if you look in the mirror
you're you're like oh no that's I don't
I don't look like Kieran nightly at
all so does that mean if you don't see A
Mir you're walking around thinking you
look like you're
nightly I assume they're whistling at me
yes they were probably whistling at you
uh you're also in uh 22 Jump Street
coming out soon indeed
yes I want to get this right Sony asked
me gave me some bullet points to mention
uh action summer comedy
penis
big penis action great no I don't one of
those words doesn't seem
[Music]
like